in this video i'm going to talk to you
about the number one strategy of the
ultra wealthy to avoid taxes and get the
lowest interest rate loans humanly
possible or even imaginable or
fathomable to humans if you don't know
hi my name is oxfosi i own
acquisitions.com it's a portfolio of
companies over 100 million dollars here
i have nothing to sell you i make these
videos because i'm insane and i like
being in wife beaters in a closet i'm
kidding i make these because a lot of
people are broke and i don't want you
one of them i too was broke for a very
long period of time and it sucked and so
i hope that we can at least attenuate
that situation so that you can then ask
the larger questions of what is even
worth it to begin with and you can come
to those conclusions on your own that
being said how do i get one to two
percent loans or as they call them
margin right loans on margin uh to buy
[ __ ] right or buy more assets or
whatever all right so quick overview of
what this topic is you've heard me maybe
talk about this in other videos which is
like if you have let's say 100 000 in
stocks okay you have 100 000 in stocks
depending on who you work with if you
work with a more established bank and
you have a longer relationship with them
let's say you you know bank or you do
wealth management with merrill lynch you
will have a banker and they will tell
you how to do this but i'm guessing that
if you ask the question to your courage
you click on this video you don't have
that all right so those banks will
typically give 50 60 sometimes 65
of the total assets in your portfolio as
a asset-backed loan which is a margin
based loan right and so that means that
if i had a hundred thousand dollars and
i had 65 that i could take as a loan
then i could get an additional 65 000 at
one to two percent which is crazy mind
you the interest rates can't change over
time but for the you know for a very
long period of time it's been one to two
percent all right which is very very
very very low and the nice thing about
this is that there's no closing costs
there's no fees there's no startups
there's no nothing you just pay the
interest while you hold the money and
all you have to do is pay back and then
your interest payments stop all right so
it's nice as a revolving credit line for
stuff that you want to make a quick
purchase and then give it back right
that is how it's you do buying on margin
alright that's that's where the term
comes from many of you guys have asked
how do i actually do this great question
so what we're going to do is we're going
to travel together through the the
realms of time and we're going to use
this new mystical mystical thing and i
want to i want to teach this process to
you because i think that it's very very
valuable it also serve you for answering
any of the questions that you have in
your life google all right so take loans
against stocks let's see here oh look it
looks like there's a lot of people who
are willing to do this for us let's see
if alex did something ahead of time he
sure did we clicked this guy and let's
see what it says they explained a little
bit more how useful and if i wanted to
borrow on margin
apply for margin that's all you have to
do and if you're like well i don't bank
with fidelity well i'll bet you that
wherever you bank they do this now let's
say uh robin hood margin margin oops
margin loans there we go let's look here
what is margin investing let's click
they give us an answer unless it
deposits blah blah blah you can upgrade
to robin hood gold that's how we have to
do it and that will allow you to then
borrow on margin and so all you have to
do is sign up upgrade to robinhood gold
and see what it does
all right and so the reason i do this is
because sometimes i get questions that
have answers that are googleable and so
please for the love of god one of the
best ways to stay poor is to have a
question and then not google the answer
post a comment in something and then say
well i guess i scratched my itch i asked
the question no find the answer right
and so the reason that this by
margin-based loans things like that are
useful is that they are tax-free all
right so if you wanted to pay for stuff
and this is what the ultra wealthy do
when they go ipo and they've got a
billion dollars worth of stock in
something they just take loans against
those stocks they don't have to pay
income tax they take loans against the
stock they buy stuff and the amount that
the stock goes up year over year exceeds
what they borrow they can borrow more
and then keep doing that until they die
and never pay taxes all right that's how
this works now the risks
so the risks of doing this are that
let's say for some reason you borrowed
at and i think uh there's other ones
there's like m1 finance i think is one
that i that i heard of that does up to
35
and the percentages will vary based on
the size of your portfolio how long
you've been doing business blah blah
blah right and so it's usually 30 to 60
ish all right and so let's say that you
took out a 60 you maxed this puppy out
right on your hundred thousand dollars
let's say that your portfolio because of
a crash in the marketplace drops to 50
000 so you took 60 right and now your
portfolio is worth 50. well
to to to be in accordance with the the
risk tolerance that they have you need
to be 60
of the new 50 000 value which means
that's 30 000 is what you're allowed to
borrow which means you have to pay back
the 30 of the 60 that you borrowed
originally
and if you don't have the money they
sell your [ __ ]
crazy i know it sucks that being said
that is the risk and that is why people
lose their asses on margin now as a
quick transition to this the reason um
and you might ask alex do you borrow a
margin i have in the past i have also
repaid it back quickly i tend to use
margin for very short term type things
so like six months 12 months transaction
stuff so like if i do like private
lending for hard money loans things like
that that's a perfect thing for me so
it's like if i'm making 12
or 15 or 20 on the money from a hard
money loan i can borrow at one to two
and i know i'm gonna get paid back and
the money that i'm lending out i'm
securing against another asset so if
they don't pay me back i get the asset
and then i can sell the asset and pay
back right that's how i do it that being
said i am not a huge like at this
current moment this current juncture in
time i have zero debt not even a
mortgage and you may be like alex you're
crazy probably probably but for me i
sleep really well at night knowing that
i just don't own anyone anything and for
me the objective of money was freedom
not more money just a side note now i do
subscribe to something dave ramsey said
that really resonates with me he said
i'm paraphrasing that
debt is a version of risk and risk if
extended over a long enough time horizon
exposes you to zero meaning you could
lose it all and since life is long that
means that there is a high possibility
between now and the time you die that
you do have one of these situations
where you could get exposed to zero and
for me i would rather not sacrifice what
i do have and that i do want and need
for more of something that i don't want
or necessarily don't need because me
doubling my money makes no difference in
my life but me losing all my money makes
a very big difference and so for me why
risk something that i don't want to lose
for something that i don't need and so
for that reason i have been not a big
leverage proponent in general i am very
very under levered in general all right
and so i have run my life that way and
i've focused my life on increasing the
value of the assets that i have i mean
just continuing to do that rather than
juice everything through debt and that's
just not my game personally and we still
built a nine figure net worth without
any of that and so i think you can do it
and maybe i'm selling which is very
possible and maybe when i'm 60 i'll
think that i was an absolute idiot for
thinking that way it's very possible
because you know what we learn things
and we grow but as current state alex in
2022 uh april i uh i don't think that so
anyways keep being awesome keep crushing
mozination i hope they give you some
illumination to like how do you do
margin loans um my recommendation to you
as a final parting words and disclaimer
around this is that if you were going to
partake in this in this risk okay
because it is risk borrow significantly
less than the limit all right so if you
want to use the your you know borrow on
margin probably 10 bar 20 tops keep it
way underneath so that there's literally
no way that a margin call would come up
where you'd actually have to sell some
of your stuff because the thing is is
the moment when
they get you to sell it is the moment
when it's worth the least all right so
you get double hosed all right so you
lose the power of the money that you had
and then you have to sell stuff at a
massive loss all right so that's when
you want to be buying and instead you're
selling and that's what crashes markets
a lot of people borrow that way and
that's when they ride the bull and bear
cycles and we want to be a little
smarter and try not to do what everyone
else is doing so that we can have what
no one else has all right so mosey
nation keep being awesome i make these
videos because i enjoy it apparently and
uh i do this because you know maybe some
of you guys will crush it and cross 3
million or 10 million
and uh want to work with us at
acquisition.com so we can get you to 50
and beyond so keeping awesome love you
all see you next vid bye